يعقد وزراء داخليته الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اسبانيا اجتماعا لمناقشه معاهده اتحاديه
حول الهجره واللجوء والسردود فعل متباينه
على ضفتين متوسط بشان اتفاقيه عقدها
الاتحاد مؤخرا مع تونس وجهت لها انتقادات
تتهمها بعقد صفقه يدعم بمقتضاها الاتحاد
الرئيس سعيد عبر مساعدات الاقتصاديه
محدوده مقابل الصد تونس لمواجهه لموجات
الهجره تجاه اوروبا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا لنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما اهم النقاط التي اثارت
الجدل بين دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وبين دول
الضفه الجنوبيه للمتوسط في اتفاق الهجره
التي عقده الاتحاد مع تونس واثار انتقادات
عديده
واي انعكاسات سابقه وحاليه لهذا النهج في
التعاطي مع ملف الهجره غير النظاميه في
ضوء ما يتعرض له المهاجرون في تونس وغيرها
من معامله على مستوى الخطاب الرسمي
والتعامل الامني والانساني كذلك
والى اين يسير هذا الملف واي مستقبل ينتظر
اتفاق الهجره بين دول ضفتين المتوسط
بالنظر الى التحذيرات الصادره بشان
تداعيات محتمله يصفها المنتقدون بالخطيره
والتي ترتبط بالهجره غير النظاميه
[موسيقى]
سواء سميناها اتفاقا او مذكره للتفاهم
يبقى الجدل منصبا على البنود التي اتفق
بشانها الاتحاد الاوروبي مع السلطات
التونسيه فيما يتعلق بالجهود المشتركه
لمكافحه الهجره غير الشرعيه هجره مثلت
جانبا مهما من اجتماع اسبانيا غير الرسمي
لوزراء داخليه الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وذلك بهدف التوصل لرؤيه اتحاديه
مشتركه بشانه وسط مؤشرات على وجود خلافات
في الصدد داخل البيت الاوروبي في ظل حديث
عن المغرب كنسخه مقبله محتمله لتعميم
اتفاق تونس تتصاعد الانتقادات لذلك
الاتفاقات لذلك الاتفاق عفوا من جهه عده
منظمه العفو الدوليه مثلا قالت ان مذكره
التفاهم بين تونس والاتحاد الاوروبي توسع
سياسات فاشله بشان الهجره وفي الاتجاه
نفسه قالت منظمته في مرحله ما بعد الاتفاق
ارتكبت قوه الامن والجيش في تونس انتهاكات
خطيره بحق مهاجرين غير نظاميين خبراء
مستقلون واخرون تابعون للامم المتحده
طلبوا من جانبهم مع السلطات التونسيه بوقف
ما سموه الطرد الجماعي للمهاجرين الافارقه
من البلاد
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من امس الدكتور
حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جنيف من تونس معنا ملك الخالدي
المختص في قضايا الهجره واللجوء والاتجار
بالبشر ومن ميلانو مجدي الكرباعي الناشط
السياسي والحقوقي المختص في قضايا الهجره
واللجوء اهلا بكم جميعا فيما وراء الخبر
ابدا معك دكتور حسني عبيدي يعني عندما
تقول او تطالب فاندر لاين اسبانيا
ربما تقريب وجهات النظر هذا يوحي بانها
ثمه خلاف والسؤال هل
الاوروبيون فعلا على قلبي رجل واحد هنا
وما حجم الخلاف بينهم
هناك خلافات كبيره ومتعدده بين الدول
الاوروبيه فيما يخص الاداره المشتركه
والاداره الاوروبيه للهجره وعلى العديد من
الوزراء يقولون بان في النهايه قضيه
الهجره ليست بالضروره اوروبيه ويمكن ان
تكون هناك احترام لسياده اي دوله النقاط
الاساسيه هو ان
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه تقول بان ضد
لاين لم تستطع مقاومه الضغط الكبير من قبل
رئيسه التله ورئيسه الحكومه الايطاليه
التي هي تعاني من ضغط شديد صحيح على
شواطئها وبالتالي طلبه الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان يتخذ موقفا والا فان ايطاليا لن تتمكن
لن تتمكن ولن تسمح في النهايه بوصول
المهاجرين ولذلك راينا زيارتين لمارك روتي
رغم ان حكومته مستقيله بالاضافه الى
بندلاين الاتحاد الاوروبي كان يريد فقط
انقاذ الحكومه الايطاليه ومساعده الدول
الاوروبيه حتى لا تتنازل ايطاليا على حق
باعتبار ان ايطاليا هي الوجهه الاولى
الخلافات تتعاون مجالات متعدده مثلا قضيه
اليه مراقبه هذه الاتفاقيه كيف يمكن الربط
ما بين التنميه الاقتصاديه الموعوده لتونس
وقضيه ثانيه هي اصلا ليست تونس لديها
مسؤوليه وهي قضيه الهجره الغير النظاميه
والنقطه الثالثه هي قضيه كما اشار اليها
العديد من النواب المنتمين الى تيار واحد
داخل البرلمان الاوروبي وهي ان هذا
الاتفاق هل هو في النهايه
على بياض للرئيس قيس سعيد او قبول بالنظام
لمناقشه هذه النقاط بعد قليل ولكن اسالك
استاذ مالك الخالدي
من اهم النقاط التي استوقفتك انت في
الاتفاقيه التي ابرمت بين الاتحاد وتونس
المشكل في هذه النقاط الموجوده في هذا
الاتفاق انها غير واضحه ليس الينا فقط
مختصون كمختصين في هذا المجال وانما لي
العديد من المكونات المجتمع المدنيه التي
تعمل على قضايا الهجره واللجوء منذ سنوات
جاءت في الحقيقه جاءت معممه في اكثرها
ولكن ما هو ظاهر في هذا الاتفاق هو عمليه
الترحيل القصري والجماعي للمهجين
التونسيين اول مهاجرين من جنسيات افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء سيدتي الكريمه ان كل مهاجر
يتم ترحيله من بلد ما مهما كان هذا البلد
دون رضاه هو يعتبر ترحيل قصري وهذا حسب
القوانين والمعاهدات الدوليه
وضعيه الانسان داخل دوله ما تتطلب دراسه
حاله بحاله لكل شخص مهاجر وهذه الاتفاقيات
التي تقوم على طرد الجماعي والترحيل
القصري بالتونسيين او من افريق جنوب
الصحراء تطرح اكثر من سؤال حول وضعيه
المهاجرين كل موضوع انسان يؤخذ على بعد
سياسي تصبح هناك مشاكل وهذه المواضيع التي
تطرح مثل قضايا الهجره واللجوء هي مواضيع
اجتماعيه انسانيه بالاساس فاتخاذ بعد
سياسي في ابتزاز تونس بتمويلها بتسعمائه
مليون اورو في المقابل بترحيل التونسيين
من ايطاليا او من الفضاء الاوروبي والجديد
في هذه الاتفاقيه هو ترحيل التونسيين من
فضاء شينج كيمي يعني من الاتحاد الاوروبي
كاملا نعرف ان هناك اتفاقيات اتفاقيات 97
مع ايطاليا اتفاقيه ما بعدها وصلت الى
حدود 2017 مع المانيا في الترحيل القصري
للمهاجين ولكن هذه المره الجديده التي
يطرح في هذه القضيه هو الترحيل القصري من
الفضاء الشنغن بالاضافه الى ذلك هو جعل
تونس وكانها نقطه عبور ترحيل المهاجرين
غير النظاميين ثالثا نقطه اخرى مهمه وهي
تمويل تونس او تقديم تونس مساعدات لحمايه
الحدود الفضاء الاوروبي بالرغم من ان
الرئيس التونسي عبر في اكثر من مره عن
رفضه ان تكون تونس يعني حارس الحدود
للفضاء الاوروبي ولا ايطاليا ولكن بتقديم
مساعدات امنيه للقوات البحريه على البحر
الابيض المتوسط ايضا يطرح اكثر من سؤال
حول ماذا ستقوم تونس بهذه الاليات
والمعدات خاصه وان الاتهامات موجوده
للقوات الامنيه التونسيه بعمليات يعني
عمليه حمايه حراسه الحدود ليس في المياه
الاقليميه التونسيه وانما خارج هذه المياه
اذا 900 مدينه مراحل متعدده
السؤال الابرز يبقى هل نعرف كل شيء عن هذا
الاتفاق مجدي الكرباعي يعني
قبل قليل مالك الخالدي كان يقول الظاهر
على الاقل ما نعرفه ظاهريا هل هناك جزء
ظاهر وجزء غير معلن ضمني برايك لا نعرفه
حتى الان
شكرا على الاستضافه يعني تقريبا هذه هي
كانت رده فعل يعني الراي العام السياسي
وكذلك الراي العام الاعلامي في اوروبا
وخاصه في ايطاليا يعني يقولون بان هذه
الاتفاقيه فيها الغام كثيره هناك يعني
كلام في المطلق لا يوجد تفسير واضح للنقاط
وخاصه النقطه التي تتعلق الهجره والتي
يعني شكلت تجاذب خاصه في الراي العام
السياسي الايطالي ولونا ان اليوم من
المخجل ان تقوم باوروبا
بامضاء مذكره من هذا القبيل مع
نظام في تونس نظام يعني
يستعمل في الكتابه عبارات عنصريه يستعمل
في خطاب كذلك عباره يعني
ينجدون بها الاوروبيين خاصه الامارات التي
يستعمل هذه تغيير التركيبه الديموغرا
والتي نحن
كمهاجرين نعيش في اوروبا نسمعها كثيرا من
المتطرف سواء كان من اوربان في المجر
وجورج هنا في ايطاليا وكذلك لبنان في
فرنسا وحزب بوكس في اسبانيا يعني اليوم
نرى ان هناك دوله في شمال افريقيا تستعمل
هذه
العبارات وهذا ما شكل يعني قلق في هذه
الاتفاقيه
الاتفاقيه تاتي بعض الذي حصل في شخص من
طرد جماعي لمهجين
كذلك مساله الترحيل القصري للمهاجرين
التونسيين وانا اعاقب على المتداخل ليس
التجاج يعني تحليل التنشين من قضاء اذا
ذهبنا ولاحظنا يعني
التقرير الذي تنشره الاتحاد الاوروبي
والارقام من اورستات نجد ان تقريبا معظم
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ترحل الى تونس
باعداد
تونس تاتي يعني في المرتبه الاولى من عدد
الملاحرين وخاصه هنا اتحدث
وهذا سيشكل نوعا ما كذلك يعني
قلق بالنسبه لمنظمات الحكوميه هنا
اعرض بالف
عل كل هذه التصريحات للرئيس وكبته النعره
العنصريه الواضحه التي بدت في الشارع
التونسي وخصوصا في صفاقس والسؤال هو هذا
النهج الاوروبي مع تونس كيف انعكس على
القضيه برمتها خصوصا مع حديث السلطات
الليبيه عن طرد عدد من اللاجئين من تونس
باتجاه ليبيا في ظروف قاسيه للغايه
هو دائما الخطاب السياسي شرعا لكل ما يحدث
فيه اشاره نحن في تونس وتحدث تقنيا لدينا
القوانين التي تحمي حقوق الانسان وتحمي
حقوق الافراد بصفه عامه يعني هنا نتحدث
تقنيه لدينا قوانين مصادقه عليها تونس
منها قانون 51 لحمايه اللاجئين من ايضا
بروتوكول 67
المتمم لهذه الاتفاقيه تونس مو صادقه على
بعض القوانين منها ايضا قانون 2018
عدد 61 لمكافحه الاتجار بالبشر ولكن عندما
يكون الخطاب السياسي فيه نوع من النعرات
العنصريه او التمييزيه يصبح الشارع
التونسيه الذي يتبنى هذا الخطاب السياسي
عنيف نوعا ما نحو فئه معينه اديسته لسيده
الكريمه تحمي حقوق الاقليات ولا تحمي حقوق
الاغلبيه وهذا ما هو ما جاءت به فلس
اذا هذا سيؤثر على انطباعات الراي العام
اثر ايضا والمشكل ان
السلطه السياسيه
جعلت كل المواطنين صفاقس يواجهون هذه
الازمه لوحدهم دون تدخل ماذا فعلت السلطه
السياسيه في حمايه اللاجئ في حمايه
المهاجرين في توفير التغطيه الصحيه في
توفير العديد من الخدمات هذا اثر وغالبا
ما وجد هؤلاء الذين يعتبرون فئه مستضعفه
داخل
الفضاء التونسيه وداخل الدوله التونسيه
مما جعلهم يذهبون نحو الفضاء الى الى
المعاينه يعني في اشاره لصفقه مركبه نحاول
ان نفهم ابعادها في الواقع الدكتور حسني
عبيدي انت في بدايه الحوار الشرط الى وجود
انتقادات من مسؤوله من منظمه العفو
الدوليه من جهات كثيره مثلا مسؤوله منظمه
الدوليه تحدثت عن طواطئ اوروبي في زياده
معاناه الافارقه يعني اذا وضعنا هذا على
جنب هذا يعني شغلهم هذا موضوعهم ولكن
نواب داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وهنا المفارقه
ينتقدون ويتهمون المفوضيه يقولون انكم
تبيعون قيم الاتحاد
وتنتهكون التزامه
بمناهضه النظم الدكتور
وهنا يعني هذا هو ما يفتح الباب على
السؤال عن هذه الصفقه ان وجدت برايك
يعني حتى دول كبيره مثل المانيا تحفظت
نوعا ما على سلوك
وباعتبار ان هناك قضايا اساسيه تهتم بها
المانيا وتهتم بها دول اوروبيه هي قضيه
اقتراب دائما اي اتفاقيه خاصه عندما تسمى
اتفاقيه شراكه شامله
ان تقترن بقضايا خاصه بحقوق الانسان
بقضايا الحوكمه الى غير ذلك هذا لم يكن
اصلا يعني في المسوده الاولى يجب ان ننسى
بان هذه اتفاقيه وضعها القانوني اتفاقيه
دوليه وبالتالي الدول الاخرى الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي لمطالبه قبل كل شيء
بالمصادقه عليها قبل ان يتم
ان تصبح ساريه المفعول لكن لا يعني اخفي
عليك سيدتي بان هناك ارتياح لدى وزاره
الداخليه وهم يترقبون فعلا اذا استطاعت
اذا استطاع الاتحاد الاوروبي التمرير هذه
الاتفاقيه ان يتم استنساخ هذه الاتفاقيه
ويقولون بان في النهايه ما تم التوقيع بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي كل دوله وتركيا كان في
النهايه يعني عملا من على الحد او التقليل
من عدد المهاجرين من تركيا الى اوروبا
فهناك المفارقه صحيح هناك يعني احتياجات
احتياجات كبيره من قبل العديد من النواب
داخل البرلمان الاوروبي حول قضايا يعني لم
يتاتم احترامها او كيف يمكن في النهايه
كما قلت يعني ان نقرن ما بين قضيه الهجره
وقضيه حقوق الانسان وقضيه وقضيه قبول رئيس
قيس سعيد هناك بعيد وقالوا بان الاتفاقيه
في روحها تشبه الاتفاقيه اخرى لم تؤدي
نتيجه واتفاقيه نادي ابرمت مع ايطاليا اي
اختزال المقاربه في فقط الحل الامني اثبت
محدوديته بالنسبه للعديد من المنتقدين ليس
لديهم هذه نسخه ربما متطوره والقضيه كما
اثرت الاستنساخ هذا ما يثير قلق كثير من
المنظمات مالك الخالدي يعني وعبر عن ذلك
صراحه يقولون انه هناك خطر من يعتبر هذا
نموذج يحتذى ما حصل في تونس وانه سيتم
ربما فقط هذه بدايه المشوار وسيتم ربما
عقد اذا اردنا ان نسميها صفقات اخرى من
هذا النوع في المستقبل قريب كيف ترى انت
افق الافق
هناك حديث عن ابرام اتفاقيه مماثله مع مصر
مع
المغرب ولكن
سيحاول الاتحاد الاوروبي والحكومات
اليمنيه المتطرفه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان تذهب نحو هذا المنوال ولكن بكل الازمات
التي يعيشها العالم وخاصه في الشرق الاوسط
وبعض البلدان ايضا والحرب الروسيه الركنيه
المتواصله حدود الان كل هذه الازمات التي
يعيشها العالم الاقتصاديه والانسانيه لن
تزيد كل هذه الاتفاقيات الا سوءا الوضع
الانساني وخاصه في قضايا الهجره خاصه مع
مشاكل التغيرات المناخيه وهذا مثبت
بالتقارير الاماميه لو يدرك الاتحاد
الاوروبي او يعتقد ان هذه الاتفاقيه مع
تونس ستقلص من تدفقات الهجره نحو الفضاء
الاوروبي وهو مخطئ تمام يمكن ان تقلص
بنسبه ضئيله جدا بهذه المقاربه الغير
الانسانيه بترحيل قصريا المهاجرين وانما
ستزيد من تدفقات الهجره نحو الفضاء
الاوروبي بالرغم من 900 مليون اورو بهذا
بالرقم ايضا ليس له ليس بكبير جدا ولكن
واقعيا ستحاول سيحاول اتحاد الاوروبيه
بعضرفه الذهاب نحو حكومات اخرى التي
ستحاول ابتزاز الاتحاد الاوروبي في
المقابل ترحيل المهاجرين الغير النظامين
الموجودين في الفضاء من هذه الحكومات
الاخرى كل صراحه دكتور حسني عبيدي والمغرب
يعني كثيرون يتحدثون ان المغرب هي
الوجهه القادمه هل ترى فعلا ان هناك ربما
سينجح الاوروبيون في اقناع المغاربه ثم
يقنعون ايضا الجزائريين
من المقبل برايك
يعني الجزائرين مشكله اعتقد يعني
استثنائيه لانه اصلا الجزائر خير يعني
اعربت عن عدم الرضاعه على المفاوضات
الخاصه بقضيه الهجره وتقول بانها غير
معنيه لكن معك حق في قضيه المغرب لان
المغرب اصلا الاسبان حكومه
يعني دائما تشير باتفاقها مع المغرب وتقول
بانه حقق النتائج
سبقته يعني اجتماعات بين تبون وميلوني
ويعني كانت تونس في
صحيح لكن بالنسبه لقضيه علقه يعني بالنسبه
لسبته وبليبيا يعني لم تصبح تحت الضغط
الكبير للمهاجرين مثل ما كان في السابق
مثل قبل الاتفاقيه هناك انتظار قبل كل شيء
للانتخابات المقبله في شهر يوليو اذا كان
الحزب الذي سيفوز سيحافظ على هذا الاتفاق
اعتقد اذا تم المحافظ على هذا الاتفاق
الذي ابرم بين المغرب واسبانيا فمن المؤكد
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يجد صعوبه مع
المغرب بشرط كما تعلمين دائما المغرب لديه
شروط كبيره واحيانا تعجيزيه قبل بعض الدول
الاوروبيه قضيه مثلا الاعتراف بالحكم
بالمغربيه الصحراء وقضايا اخرى خاصه مثلا
بقضيه تاشيرتها غير ذلك فانا اتفق مع
الزملاء في ان قضيه الهجره ستؤدي الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى كل مره التنازل ليس
فقط عن القيم وانما حتى بعض القضايا
الاساسيه التي تعم الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه
يخشى فعلا بان تكون هذه الهجره هي التي
تقنع العديد من الاوروبيين التصويت بصفه
مطلقه ودائمه لليمين هناك خشيه كبيره يعني
اصلا اليمين متطرف اصبح الان يعني لديها
اليد الطول في البرلمان في الحكومات
الاوروبيه لكن الخوف هو ان تقول بان يجب
ان لا نترك قضيه الهجره الغير نظاميه في
ايدي النبيله المتطرف فقط ولابد كل
الحكومات امكن ان تعتني كذلك انت برايك
سيد مجدي الكرباعي ما هي الرساله التي
تبعث بها هذه الاتفاقيه مع تونس في اكثر
من اتجاه وفي النهايه من الرابح والخاسر
هنا
هي رساله اول شيء سياسيه لانه نراه كيف
جورج ميلوني وفيه لايقاتها الانتخابيه وهي
جعل دول شمال افريقيا مناطق حدوديه متقدمه
هذا هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى هناك كذلك
يعني تفاصيل في هذه الاتفاقيه وهو وانا
اريد يعني ان اقف عند وهو
ما هي التعاون الامني ما معنى التعاون
الامني ان اليوم يحق لوكالات استخبارات
الحدوديه مثل وكذلك
البوليس الاوروبي انا يقوم بتنسيق او يقوم
بعمليات داخل التراب التونسي وهذا ما تحدث
عليه
عندما قال سنشكل نقاط استخباراتيه في
الموانئ مثل موانئ وبالتالي هذه هي
الرساله التي تريد ان تبعثها اوروبا الى
دول شمال افريقيا ان اليوم عليها ان تنسق
معادن وان تجعل يعني هذه الحدود هي حدودها
الاولى امام المهاجرين هذا هو يعني الذي
تريد ان تصل اليه اوروبا من خلال انها
يعني تجعل دول شمال افريقيا مناطق حدوديا
متقدمه تتجمع فيها يعني المهاجرين
وبالتالي بعد نرى كذلك في هذه الاتفاقيه
كيف على تونس ان تقوم بترحيل المهاجرين من
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء الى دولا قبل ان
يصلوا هنا
الرابط طبيعه الحال هي اوروبا والخاسر في
هنا دواء دول شمال افريقيا وخاصه تونس
التي تعيش ازمه كذلك سياسيه مما جعل
الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم يذهب
معها في اطار هذه الشراكه وهذه الشراكه
كذلك ستشمل عده مجالات اخرى مثل شارك يعني
هذه الشركه يعني تولد شركات اخرى مثل شركه
لاليكا التي التي تعنى بها يعني
المشاركه او التوافق او الاتفاقيه الشامله
في نفوس الاقتصادي والمجال كذلك الفلاح
والخدمات هي وثيقه
استعمالها تم رفضها
[موسيقى]
وشكرا جزيلا
لمجدي الكربعي من ميلانو الناشطه السياسي
والحقوق المختص في قضايا الهجره واللجوء
كذلك اشكر مالك الخالدي من تونس المختص في
قضايا الهجره واللجوء والاتجار بالبشر
ونشكركم ايضا مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر فيما لا
[موسيقى]